good morning apartment ah here it is
instructions to fit in have everybody
like you can always be happy
step 1 showers and always be sure to
keep the soap out of your ass oh my gosh
I love this song
guys wait up
we much come with me if you want enough
my fellow master-builders including but
not limited to Superman Wonder Woman the
mermaid green ninja 1980-something space
guy Michelangelo Michelangelo we have
learned that Lord business plans to end
the world as we know it there is yet one
hope the special has arisen I wasn't
listening what is happening you're the
most important person in the universe
release the cover chopper
everybody I'm here back man hahaha who
are you here to see I'm here to see your
bud oh my gosh wait first try I'm the
boss I'm rides all active robots destroy
awesome - the backfield tearing it to
the invisible jet
dang it
take them to the melting chamber isn't
there supposed to also be a good cup hi
buddy would you like a glass of water
yeah actually too bad
we'll wing it that's a bad pun hey guys
I think we're about to crash into the
Sun yeah but it's gonna look really cool
you